THE FINAL CHAPTER OF THE OT, CHD
SIMON COULDN'T GATHE AT ZEGRAS.
PASS TO THE SLOT, ZEGRAS.
AND WHAANNOT TURN PUCKS OVER
LIKE THAT WITH THAT LINE ON THE
ICE.
IT IS A GEED IT.
>> Josh: HINTZ ON THE TOP LINEN
AND SCORES.
ZACH ASTON-REESE.
KIVIRANTA HOLDS UP.
ALL AN APPETIZER FOR WHAT COMES
ANGLED LOW.
THE SHOT PINBALLED AROUND.
RADULOV.
GIBSON NEVERERBOUNCED OFF OF OE
TO THE SIDE OF THE NET.
>> Daryl: YOU CAN SEE AT TIMES
THE STARS ARERE FAKSA.
DALLAS STILL IN.
ROBERTSON, A BACKHAND AND OFF OF
THE BAR
RADEK RAN HOCKEY HALL OF
FAME IN
BEHIND THE NET, IN
>> Daryl: WELCOME TO THE GAME
MR. STOLARZ.
MISSING THE PLAYOFFS.
BUT RADULOV WALKS IT LOU  FRONT
SCORE.
WHAT A SET UP BY 20
MINUTES.
HE IS NOT OUT F F RIGHT WING SI.
BACKHAND.
KICKED
HENRIQUE, WHO
ITF SUSTR.
WITH A MINUTE TO GO
>> Daryl: OETTINGER MIGHT GET AN
ASSIST ON THIS A